oh my days please look at that
that looks like what comes out of my
dog's bottom
yes then people i'm tom grennan and this
is snack wars uk versus island
my dad is from ireland and i want to
know who's the best
let's find out what we got
this is the classic cheese and onion
walkers gary lineker finest and this
here
is your standard tato banging
who had gary right
this is a good crisp now
this crisp here tato
oh my god done to perfection
so i'm actually going to give the win to
the taters and to the irish so well done
here we go oh
i don't know if i'm going to like any
sort of relish this one looks like hair
wax or something like that
i don't know if i'd be buying that on
the shelf i'm not gonna lie here we go
oh oop
yeah whoa
whoa actually when you put your nose in
for the third time it's like you know
when you like pick and pick your ear or
something yeah
and you go oh that smells but then you
go i'm gonna go back for another one
everybody's done that don't lie to
yourself you've done it
all right then
where have i been oh my life
this is so good like if i had a bit of
like a little bit of brie
brie cracker and a bit of bali molly
i think that says then i could
definitely definitely definitely
demolish them right let's get into the
the hair wax how the hell do you open it
oh my days all my days
please look at that
that looks like what comes out of my
dog's bottom
oh oh my god
[Music]
oh you can have that back
no way oh my god
it tastes like a gentleman's relish oh
exactly i like fish but anchovies are
awful
the irish have come through yes
i already know who's winning this
there it is the love heart there's so
much love put into this biscuit
um it is good and to be honest with you
it's a classic
i don't feel like it'd be like the
standout biscuit but i do feel that
every family would have this in the back
of the cupboard and go in
oh yeah the chapman dodgers i reacted to
this biscuit though because oh
my god
oh these are so good
the irish have taken another another
point
the jam mellows ha ha
a thing of beauty i'm gonna eat you all
now
oh
this is a drink that again when you go
home
back to ireland this will always be
in your aunties or granny's
or granddad's fridge and they're like
saidona saidona saidona saidona and you
know
what's coming
um now into the vimto
oh come on you sit there and you go
hit shoes in the mouth every taste party
is going
yes we are vimto in we are out on the
bow we are out with the boys we're out
with the girls having a good one
for me this is a tough one it is a
really tough one
i have to go with a vimto because vimto
is it's just banging
to be sure to be sure the irish have won
who are
[Music]
[Laughter]
cool gotcha egg
[Music]
poor chicken man